Tim Elizabeth I need you to know we
brought in this Christmas tree just for
you guys what do you think I love it it
looks it looks amazing I'm feeling very
Christmassy right kind of the middle of
the Christmas tree I know I'm kind of
blocking it I know does it have a star
on the top of it
it doesn't oh no it's like okay we'll
see you in a little bit we'll see we'll
see a little bit
I'm I will have that star for you
um I just have to say I am such a huge
fan of the Santa Claus films uh such a
big part of my childhood Elizabeth I
want to know what was it like working
with your dad on this because it's hard
to believe this is your acting debut you
are such a natural thank you
um I cannot say enough I say this you
know every time it was such a joy I
can't you know I I can't express my the
my how grateful I am for this
opportunity and how fun it was
um he was probably cracking jokes I
think 24 7 off and on set
um between takes it was just so much fun
and I learned so much and he was just
amazing
is Tim like that at home cracking jokes
all the time oh oh yes that that
um yeah yeah pretty much that don't work
so well
I'm the judge at home Kenneth yeah it's
a little awkward even talking about it
because I did it one time one time she's
doing some speech for school or
something and she did a joke and I mean
in the middle of dinner I went nothing
my wife goes is that funny I didn't land
I mean
and now he's paying back for that one
constantly every time I'm doing bits at
the table or whatever she'll just real
didn't land no well okay to be honest
this is how it started so I would you
know as as a natural like toddler three
four you know two three four years old I
would you know make dumb jokes that
literally were not funny or did not make
any sense and he wouldn't laugh like a
parent should laugh at a toddler it's
like you know Mommy laughing and stuff
and he wouldn't laugh so he's paying
back for all these that he just didn't
he didn't decide to listen to my jokes
so huh
be cutting very awkward all of a sudden
are you saying this is the best
interview of the month for me
Tim did
it work at all having your
working office
quick story Patricia Richardson on Home
Improvement would sometimes be so real
and I wasn't used I was just a stand-up
comic have been my whole I still do
concerts she'd look at me and say stuff
and I go
well I'm sorry cut she seems to be angry
she goes I'm acting I go oh wow because
it looks like you're really acting and
you she'd teach me how to look into her
eyes and listen to what she had to say
that's an acting thing and I learned the
craft of acting
we do a great emotional scene where
Sandra that she plays is having a
problem and she delivered it so well
that
I showed up the dad and said well that I
feel bad that you hurt but I was doing
the line of it and it made it's so
emotional that I'm looking in her eyes
and I'm going I really wanted to make
her feel better like you would as a
parent as a dad and then she was acting
like a daughter and it was very organic
and I gave her a lot of credit I don't
know
this was all a surprise to her mom and I
and certainly on set it showed that she
really does this very well honors the
skill of acting knows the value it comes
from the writing and the staff and the
crew and all that that you really very
little part of that but on camera that
moment one of my good friends is a
photographer on the set was getting all
teared up so that was so emotional I
said yeah I was there and it it it it it
it it it really affected me and I said
that scene
it's the benefit of having someone that
you know and love this much and it came
through in that particular character but
what are the chances that she gets a gig
on the thing as a little girl her age
and she's also the daughter of the the
main character it was it's all
coincidental and she she did a very good
job honoring that you absolutely did it
was so much fun watching those scenes
together with you guys thank you so much
uh such a big fan of this series the
fans are gonna love it I know we
answered me a lot of questions remember
this is going to be fun when you get to
see how we did this and what power she
has and how Mrs Claus her character
develops and some of the bigger
questions anybody's had about that first
one we answer them all
I love it so much thank you so much
thank you